January 10th 1992 a container ship  traveling from Hong Kong to Tacoma  Washington loses 12 containers overboard  one of them sets loose thousands of tiny  yellow plastic ducks on the currents of  the North Pacific the currents carry the  ducks all over the world so months later  they start washing up on the coast of  Alaska turning this toy spell into an  accidental experiment so from the duckie  study you get real-time data about the  currents in the North Pacific The  Accidental duck experiment is still  providing information today  they're almost indestructible I mean  literally 20 years after they hit the  ocean they're still washing up on  beaches around